all right one other clip i wanted to
play this is uh this is account uh the
account woke preacher clips on twitter
kind of like the libs of tiktok but for
christians uh dug up this clip of simon
woodman he's um of london's bloomsbury
central baptist church
at some kind of panel discussion talking
about jesus
and uh informing us that apparently
jesus maybe didn't know this was
transgender
i think jesus um transgenders himself on
a number of occasions
um i i think you know just just a little
phrase jesus is lamenting over jerusalem
longing to gather jerusalem as a mother
hen gathers her chicks
and i think if you look at
the foot washing from john's gospel foot
washing elsewhere in both old and new
testament that it's consistently done by
by women and yet jesus takes that on
people often cast that as being the
servant's role it was the woman's role
and and jesus does it and becomes the
woman at that
point so transgender is a verb now too
jesus transgendered himself
i play that clip because it perfectly
captures
how transgender ideology reinforces
gender norms
while pretending to deconstruct them
so jesus becomes the woman
by taking on the quote woman's role
but why not just say that jesus proves
that the role is not just a woman's role
which
it isn't
why is it that jesus sex changes because
of the role
rather than saying the role
changes because of
his sex
you see what i'm saying what why it's
like when uh when a boy plays with um
the example i use in doctorville boy
plays with a dollhouse
you know
and for for decades
back when the left really did seem to be
and you know the feminists were more in
control of gender ideology back then and
so there was this emphasis on breaking
down gender roles and everything and so
they would have said back then that a
boy plays with the doll house and all
that does is prove that boys can play
with houses and it's not just a girl
thing
okay so they the um this idea that doll
houses are just for girls is an
artificial social construct and so this
boy is helping to break it down by
playing with the dollhouse
well now they say that when the boy
plays with the doll house it's an
indication that he's actually a girl
so you are reinforcing that stereotype
and by him engaging in that activity you
know
playing that role
it actually changes him rather than him
changing the role or the nature of the
role the role changes the nature of him
and so things have been flipped around
exactly backwards upside down
perfect example of it there well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content